following program is brought to you in
living color on nbc
[Music]
so
oh
okay
[Music]
wow
not a pretty sight is it
no
rat bites never are
but treating rat bites or all the
diseases rats cause is one thing
preventing them is another
that's where i commit
i'm jeff cannon
my job
director of rat control for the city
health department
at least that's my official title
mostly
people simply call me the rat man
that's bill barnes just leaving he's new
on the job but turning into a good rat
man himself
and so is george wilson there sometimes
george and i work together most times we
don't
but either way he's tops
been added 20 years
another rabbi jeff
a baby again mercy hospital
multiple bites and faith in hands
it shouldn't bother me after five or six
years
well it should never happen
huh don't let it get you down
think of all the cases that don't happen
because you're in there pitching
well
as usual our work was waiting
all cases of one kind or another that we
have to investigate before we can send a
crew out
where
most everywhere
we get the word from hospitals all the
police from homeowners store owners or
tenants
anybody who calls them for just one
reason
he's got rex
no sir my mother wasn't home when the
baby got beat
she worked and i keep the baby
but if you were with the baby how come
i mean i just gave her a bottle
and there's nothing wrong with batteries
there
i can't watch it every minute
you know mister the kids around here
don't care they don't care one bit
did you hear about all those rats but we
sure got them around here
i can see that
and apparently the kids aren't the only
ones who don't care
and that suits the rats just fine
listen to the rat man
all they want is a place to live
a messy place
where they can gnaw their way through
doors or loose screens
or jump right in through broken windows
holes around pipes or on the walls
just enough room for a runaway between
their food and their sheller
a place to borrow into the ground and
come up inside a building
enough rubbish to build their nest and
have another litter in less than a month
and what they want most of all
is enough to eat
there's an old saying in my business if
you're feeding them they're your rats
they'll eat most anything too
even spoiled food that would make people
sick
to them
garbage is a well-balanced diet
and the closer that food is the better
rats don't like to travel far
or in the open
or in the daytime
too dangerous
just grab a quick meal and hide that's
the way they want it
rats are smart
okay ma'am i'll notify the owners then
get a crew out here to set a poison bait
start doing some rat proofing meanwhile
you folks in the neighborhood better
start cleaning up or these rats will
help me on the street
well i don't know it sure ain't gonna be
easy but we'll try
you know they've always lived here and
probably always will
sure they always live here and why not
almost like ringing the dinner bell
forever right in town
exactly what they need and want to set
up housekeeping
that's those steel drums for you
too big for the city to handle no lifts
shouldn't be used for garbage in the
first place
something the matter rat man
yes
that's a real mess you got there
why don't you get good camps with liz
not my problem i just live here
sure
you just live here
you and the rats
rat
heck yeah we got right
man it's like i told you
i'm not the owner
i'm just the manager
besides
ain't nothing i can do
i've given you two warning notices now
you get a penalty ticket
and once the owner pays a sign in court
you can bet he'll tell you to start
acting like a real manager
look i don't want rats in my restaurant
you think i'm crazy and if the city do
its job i wouldn't have them
the city does what it can
but the citizens in this thing too
we can't keep house for you
[Music]
this used to be a good place to live
look at it now
before these old rats started coming
around
don't blame the rats lady don't blame
anybody
just keep in mind that it takes a bit of
effort on everyone's spark to keep a
neighborhood clean and neat so you won't
have rats
oh yes there are thousands of rat bike
cases every year
most of them infants with food on their
faces after eating
or
older persons
if we get them promptly for treatment
most wounds usually heal satisfactory
unfortunately many victims also suffer
from the agony and pain of rat bite
fever
biological warfare rats versus the
people you betting on the people george
sure
just the same as you are
because like you say it's war it's
everybody's business capacity that's why
more of them have got to join up
right
and if cats where the rat catches people
think they are we wouldn't be mixing
tons of poison bait rat proofing
buildings or forever holding clinics
cats dogs what's the difference
they're not much better than traps
really
like the butcher shop case well that was
before your time yeah
it was over on the west side and the
butcher used traps and he caught a rat
now and then though he figured he had
the problem licked
most people do
but man
the ones he didn't catch must have had a
picnic every night
while all those scraps no wonder he ever
caught a rat in his trap
this was all in the back room of course
so the customers had no reason to
suspect a thing
not then anyway
most people expect places that handle
food to be clean as a whistle
but they sure knew something was wrong
when that food poisoning hit them and i
mean them
men women kids
why that food was so contaminated from
rat droppings left on his table that
butcher could have poisoned a small army
proper losing his customers he got a
good pace of lepto all on his own
probably some infected rat urine and the
mop water got right into his system
anyhow he sure got the message
leptospirosis huh
complete with kills vomiting muscular
aches that's pretty serious you better
believe it
i am dr c bruce lee of the research and
development office of the environmental
control administration of the u.s public
health service
we have with us today
mr harry d pratt chief of the rodent
control branch of the environmental
control administration
how are you pratt
dr lee it's a pleasure to be here today
uh we plan to use this motion picture in
many places throughout the country where
there is a rat problem but particularly
in the 20 cities uh which are funded
under the partnership for health program
could you tell us something where these
cities are located but as you can see on
the map these 20 cities are scattered
from coast to coast
including such very large cities in
chicago
cleveland
new york
and washington
how much money is the federal government
allocating for this rat control program
well in the first year of the operations
the federal government has spent about
15 million dollars
particularly in places like chicago new
york and baltimore where their existing
program and in certain places like
atlanta and nashville are where the
money is used to start new programs
can you uh tell us some information does
the program cover an entire city no
usually there's not enough money uh to
cover an entire city uh so the work is
concentrated for effective rat control
in the low income area quite often in
the model cities or in the model
neighborhood area now that's interesting
uh in these areas who does the actual
work on the program so each program is
planned and directed by trained
engineers biologists or sanitarians with
broad experience and insect and rodent
control work and
very frequently
years of work with the health department
however the majority of the workers are
recruited from the inner city where the
control work is being carried out
you mean to say that we have uh people
working on the program who have grammar
school educations and who have been to
high school are they working on these uh
activities yes as you can see here uh
some of these men are dropouts or people
who could not go further in school
because of lack of money
however they can be trained to do very
fine work in a number of types of jobs
such as collecting rubbish
or they can be used to observe a rat
signs if you see on the corner of this
door here uh rats teeth grow four or
five inches a year and they can roll
through many building materials even
lead pipe with their sharp teeth
notice along the edge of this building a
rat runway rats feel comfortable when
they're using the same path day after
day uh between their homes and the
source of food
these signs are very interesting of rats
being about but uh what else do the men
who are engaged in the program look for
when they make an inspection well of
course the most important thing we feel
is the checking to see about
rescue storage and
garbage
because
garbage and refuse furnish the food
and
nesting material
for the rat it's amazing how many
garbage cans have no bottoms or tops
there's no place for the bottomless or
topless that in refuse storage well
since we have no place for the
bottomless or topless fat and refuge
storage
what do the control workers do when they
find
garbage cans which are unsatisfactory
well of course the first thing they do
is to come up and meet the
householder and try to get him to buy
new garbage cans
they try to get rid of old appliances
old automobiles places where rats would
hide in the backyard
this is probably the most important
thing that each householder can do is to
have good refuge storage on his own
property
well this is important to know that we
must have good store storage places for
refuge on property now our rats confined
to particular areas of a city and this
is discharged into the sewers so these
sewers then serve as a place where the
rats can hide and they can travel and of
course they can come up into some of our
very best houses right through the floor
drain
they can even crawl and swim through a
toilet into our basement now that's most
amazing and that sort of is chilling to
think that even in
my own home i could have a rat coming in
by this means
uh of course i am interested in knowing
what are the methods used for killing
ramps how do you go about killing them
but of course
on the big city program
we use three types of rodenticides that
is rat killing chemicals we use uh
the anticoagulants we use red squill and
we use zinc phosphide now the
anticoagulants are a chemical
uh which is mixed usually with yellow
cornmeal this sort of thing here
now the rats must eat this for four or
five days consecutively before their
blood begins to lose the ability to clot
or coagulate hence the name
anticoagulant
after this period of time four or five
days to a week or more
they become weak
and actually die painlessly from loss of
blood now there's a built-in safety
factor if your child for instance
should happen to eat this once or your
pet should eat this one there's actually
no danger of from one feeding no
sickness no death it must be eaten four
or five days in a row
well it's good to know this that there
is this built-in safety factor and i'm
pleased because i do have children now
i'm concerned what would i do if i found
i had rats or mice about my house well
of course if you had rats the best thing
to use are these anticoagulants because
of this built-in safety factor now they
can be bought and used in a yellow
cornmeal mix it's soft like this but it
tends to blow so a number of
manufacturers have made it in a pellet
form which does not blow around nearly
as much this comes probably in 50 or
more different types of commercial
formulations
this is fascinating to see the uh
packaging in which these poisons come
i remember as a child that they often
said that a trap was best baited with a
piece of cheese to tickle saw a rat's
nose that almost makes him sneeze now as
cheese the best bait to use for traps
well of course most housewives feel that
cheese is the best material to use in
baiting a mousetrap so it will be done
like this
and of course you put the
trap on hair trigger but actually
we have found that you can get just as
many mice or more
with uh apple or peanut butter or nut
meat or many other types of things that
are in our houses like bacon
well then what do you do about rats in
buildings for instance well of course
rats are much bigger so we use
essentially the same type of snap trap
which we would set like this
and you would put your bait here and it
would
go like that
on the other hand if this is the wall
now like this
we can sometimes trap the rats uh by
having an expanded trigger
of cardboard or metal as you see here
yes and uh you've got to be very careful
dr lee because this is something that
could catch your finger very easily as
you see now if this is the wall we don't
set the trap this way so the threat
comes in and is thrown away we try to
get it so that as the wrath travels
along the wall that way why it is caught
you see as it goes across the treadle
now there's still another type of trap
that we use that essentially is unbaited
this is called a steel trap
now this one again you can catch your
finger in and have a real uh good little
wound but if you use real caution and
set it like this
and then you come under and set it at
hair trigger remembering that one jaw of
the trap is free why then you can do it
now if this is again the thing we don't
set it this way so this rat runs along
it's thrown out you set it this way then
as the rat comes along it's caught in
the trap as you see there
these then are some of the things that
we do as we uh
try to get rid of rats and mice in our
house so i'm glad to have you the person
who's demonstrating these traps on the
on the program but what does all this
mean to the average householder
well of course to the average
householder
this means that rats are something that
they should try to get rid of
as quickly as possible
now let us look again at our motion
picture and see a little bit more about
the urban rat problems
so the rat is a stealthy clever enemy
he can climb up wires and piss
squeeze through half-inch holes
jump up and out three feet
jump down and out eight feet
even drop 50 feet and still survive
he starts fires
destroys food and valuables
contaminates even more
and when you multiply the damage of a
single rat by the rat population of the
us
about one rat for every two persons
the yearly loss skyrockets to more than
a billion dollars
so how do you change the picture
by eliminating a rat here and there not
a chance
you have to control the entire rat
population
and the first step is to eliminate the
one thing that supports any population
food
a single open garbage can for example
will support just so many rats no more
but add a few more messy cans
than the mess of the city block
plus that of an entire neighborhood
and suddenly you're supporting a
king-sized rat population
amen mr barnes
a lot of food
a lot of rats
less food
less rats
no food
no rats
way i see it
most people are so close to their rat
problem they overlook the most obvious
solution
especially when they're blaming somebody
else
there's always it boils down to
communication
to telling him point blank
look if you want to get rid of your rats
quit feeding him
quit giving him hiding places
rats won't stay in an area where they
can't get food and shelter
so
when you take it away you take away the
rats
here's the idea
see that
it's a jumbo sized always closed
container
to handle a jumbo sized garbage and
rubbish problem and it does just that
what's more
the city thinks it's great
to me
most excuses are a cover-up for doing
nothing
but if anybody
a manager
owner or tenant ever had reason to cover
up it's right inside his garbage can or
outside of it
with just a bit of conscience a bit of
pride and a bit of effort on everybody's
part
people can get rid of their rats and
they will
if everyone keeps working at it
i mean that every word of it
there's no doubt that the rat problem is
serious in every city
large or small
we can't ignore it and we can't wish it
away
but we can do something about it
each one of us
i'm betting on the people in this war on
rats
how about you
[Music]
harry your film says that the rap
problem is serious in this country just
how serious is the urban rat problem
well every big city
has a rat problem this varies of course
with the age of the housing
with the uh
condition of the housing and with the
amount of food and garbage for rats
now in the map that we showed you before
in the 20 cities where we examined are
we
found about 2 000 yards out of 12 000
carefully checked had signs of rats
outside the home this is roughly 1 6 or
but even more important uh 61 percent of
the blocks in the city had at least one
yard uh with signs of exterior rat signs
outside the home
uh
well these uh statistics the few that
you've given us are most revealing and i
was wondering does this are these
indications do they give us any uh
way of knowing what steps you're making
in uh controlling rat the rat problem
but we're making a rather sizable amount
of uh
advanced success in cutting down the
number of rat bites and in cutting down
the actual prevalence of rats in these
cities uh for instance in new york city
the number of rats uh used to be
reported uh so that there were 600 cases
of rat bites a year then in the
five-year period from 63 to 67
it dropped down to about 550. in 68
there were only 390 rat bites reported
in greater new york and this year we
only know about 200 thus far
well this does indicate that there is
progress i can remember when i was a
teacher many years ago
my children when we were discussing rats
showed me fingers and noses and ears
that had been bitten
uh by rats when they were babies this
brought home to me the importance of
control measures now i realize that much
of the film that we've seen today has
demonstrated the areas of town which we
might say are poor which are the where
people who live who don't have
opportunities however
rats are found everywhere as you said
and one of the methods of control i
assume is that we must get everybody to
cooperate meaning the tenants the
residents and the people who own the
property it's got to be a it seems to me
a a broad attack involving everybody who
has anything to do with the environment
in which rats are found did you agree to
this i would think that this is very
definitely true and that this very
definitely has a
bearing on another significant part of
the rat problem namely
about mental health and well-being you
take children that are brought up in the
inner city very frequently
they grow up
without being able to sleep at night
because the rats are up in the ceiling
or they're gnawing in the walls there's
a fear of rats you know these ugly
disfiguring uh scars and in some work
that we've done uh it seems to us that
the rats
are probably the number four cause of
unrest and turmoil in the inner city uh
following such things as human relations
and poverty and unemployment it's
interesting to feel that an animal a
small animal which has traveled with men
from asia to our country could be a
definitive cause in unrest within our
urban centers
my first experience was reading hans
lindsey's book rats lice and history
this is a rather old book but it is
still pertinent it gives the history of
man's reactions his relationships to
this
pest
this neighbor of man who has followed
without his asking man about the face of
the earth from its origin in asia
and i am more than pleased to realize
that the environmental control
administration the public health service
has within it a program which is
concerned with this rat control
are there is there any information that
uh the viewers can secure
concerning the uh control measures the
uh the activities that are being
undertaken and wrath uh of course we
feel that this is a people problem and
that we must have the people behind us
now new york has done this they have
made this sign seven things that every
new yorker should know about their
neighbor and this brings home to them
very clearly uh that these are
definitely in their homes we do a great
deal of training with health departments
all over the country and we have
recently uh produced this book control
of domestic rats and mice which is
available through the government
printing office
many health departments and other
agencies are using this with pictures of
rats and
trapping
of
rodenticides and rescue storage
all these things so go to your health
department if you have a rat problem and
get advice from your health department
thank you so much for coming aboard to
talk to us today harry it's a pleasure
my pleasure
[Music]
so
you